i just want to clarify some things
before we
before we get started
every woman is not built for the great
responsibility of being a first lady
pastor lee curtis childs faces
allegations of misconduct
his mega church may never be the same
lee curtis and i we're going to get to
the other side
hey there
yeah with a big old microphone come in
closer son you gonna see what all the
fuss is about
showtime what's up fresh is our turn
baby
lee curtis is a talent a star oh boy uh
we can edit around that
right this is gonna chronicle the
ultimate comeback
i'm rocky up in this fight
rocky didn't win but he did win in rocky
too
lord baby how many times i got to tell
you get past the first movie that was
all set up
he is just so wrong
he needs someone to harness it all right
god bless your heart i'm sure plenty of
the old congregation will come right on
back through good old ones at a greater
path to us
you have a blessed one oh my goodness
and you have a blessing
i'm a center but i'm no criminal we need
you back in that pulpit
so you can get me back on that stage
you ain't really getting that many
babies baby shake it for the lord
shake it for the lord
[Music]
[Applause]
all those folks out there who are gonna
see this
i want them to know
that i did what i was supposed to do
i just don't see how that's possible
all things are possible with god that's
matthew 19 20. yes it is
so that's good you can cut
[Music]
in theaters and streaming only on
peacock september 2nd
you